say you know what TVs Frank and I've
been getting into lately hmm who knew
yes it is safe economical way to inflict
evil on the world and it's fun too
there's a door to the mystical can you
just walk through somebody brought him
back from the grave and I want to know
how they did it that is not the edge
I take your soul
[Music]
[Laughter]
hello everybody its episode 51 of 13
o'clock man 51 I know right what was it
today what's today we're talking about
zombies some do real zombies ok so just
the historical stuff like all the
Haitian yeah it's obvious I always
thought the Blake I love modern zombie
stuff too but I always kind of like the
old the old-school folkloric zombies ok
so I kind of wanted to do a show about
that but before we get to that let's do
our regular announcements okay yeah
announcements good ok so since you guys
know the audio podcast has been moved
you can still get it on wordpress at 13
o'clock podcast and you can also it
should be available on iTunes now and
I'll put the link in the description
because I just got the recently got the
new link to where it is so you should be
able to download it from there and it
should be fine or like I said if you go
to archive.org we have a page on there
called 13 o'clock podcast and you can
just download the audio directly from
there if you want and you know like I
said the YouTube show is exactly the
same it's not moving anywhere so it's
just the audio podcast that has been
moved but you know you'll you guys will
be able to find it it's not that hard to
find so let's see what else um the show
originally didn't yes yesterday I
recorded a show with a podcast called
see you on the other side and that
actually will probably be out today yeah
what was it about well I kind of we
talked about poltergeist mostly but I
talked a little bit about my horror
fiction just talked about just general
paranormal stuff and horror stuff it was
a fun show ok
it was a really fun show to do so make
sure to check that out and what else um
spooky Empire will be coming up at the
end of October it is the last weekend in
October before Halloween it's the 27th
28th and 29th and we will be there
Orlando in Orlando I think it's at the
Orange County Convention Center that's
usually where it is it will be on
several of the panels including sick and
twisted and a bunch of the other ones
over the weekend we'll be there all
three days Friday night Saturday all day
Saturday and all day sunday
and we'll be there with all our books
and you know we'll be there to sign
stuff and have swag and all kind of neat
stuff like that so if you're in the
Orlando area the weekend before
Halloween then make sure to drop by and
say hello to us yeah we would like that
very much yes don't forget 13 o'clock in
minutes please subscribe to that one
that's our little list channel a little
list channel yes going good yeah and
hopefully I'll be able to put up another
one this week sometime we'll see how
that goes neither the end of this week I
can get another one put I also picked up
another patron there's a big patron -
yes yes like top tier yeah give em over
name Lindsay Lindsay oh thank you very
much yes yang grey will be sending you
some cool merch soon yeah yeah for and
for those in the ten dollar and up to
here we're going to do a google hangout
probably be the last weekend of August
yeah
and I'll get with with the people that
are in those beers and we'll figure out
the best time to do it yes Oh we'll get
to hang out yeah it'll be awesome and
let's see other than that just wanted to
plug my blog again goddess of hellfire
dot-com I've been writing two new horror
reviews and stuff like that on there if
you're into horror movies and stuff you
can go read all of that and I'll you
know what's funny is that that got sale
fire has its own following actually it
does go its own well like I said it's
more I mean I post stuff about the
podcast on there and I post some
paranormal stuff and you know just stuff
about my writing in general but you know
I think the anchor of it is really all
the horror movie reviews and I do other
things to just you know or self in
general like my favorite what what I
think are the scariest horror scenes and
movies and stand why they're scary and
stuff like that so you know there's a
lot of that kind of stuff on there too
so you know if you're into that go check
it out
I thought this is good too because this
is why this is one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about patient zombies is
because now we love modern zombies I
loved walking dead okay I'm a big fan I
love George Romero's movies yeah and
we've actually seen some pretty decent
zombie movies recently what was that
what was that it was Korean right you
got a Korean zombie move over set coal
train to Busan train to Busan yeah idea
if you haven't seen it I highly
recommend it yeah yeah basically zombies
on a train
but it was actually really cleverly done
the characterization was really good the
Koreans got it they like I actually was
afraid for the characters I was like oh
my god you know I was like Wiggin out
they took a lot of the best elements
from the Walking Dead series and put it
in a standalone movie yeah pretty good
the zombies were not really The Walking
Dead style zombies they were more like
that
the plague victim they were you know
fast they were fast at zombies but still
it was cool yeah it was it was really
good maybe I highly recommend it's
probably one of the best zombie movies
I've seen yeah in the last couple of
years it's in Korean yeah but it's on
Netflix I think it still is so I like
that stuff I'm not I'm not [__] on
that but you know the the modern
perception of the zombie as a reanimated
corpse that eats people
I mean that mostly stems from Night of
the Living Dead yeah I mean that's kind
of the first they were ghouls really
yeah they would know that they were
never called planted called them zombies
in that movie they remain awesome goals
yeah Romero never never saw them as a
zombie which is technically what that is
he just hungry animated corpse that eats
people that's a rule right or is
somebody that eats corpses yeah like a
Google person yes I so this is what I
thought was really interesting that I
wanted to plug a couple of my short
stories because I've written two zombie
short stories now the thing about me if
you haven't read any of my fiction is
that I don't like to write about kind of
your standard monsters werewolves
vampires if I have but if I do it then I
always want to put some kind of spin on
it or go back to the old school type of
thing you know I mean so the only two
zombie stories I ever wrote one of them
it's called understanding the reanimated
and it was in my collection associated
villainies which came out in 2011 and I
posited in that story that the Romero
zombies were real and also that Haitian
zombies were real and the main character
was like an anthropologist or like a
researcher who was trying to discover
why zombies had gone from these sugar
plantation slaves to flesh-eating ghouls
like I said so positing that both things
are real and one
why that change took place and he was
studying why that change took place and
the other zombie story I wrote which was
called the schism and it was from
hopeful monsters and that that came out
in 2009 and that one was about a
religious cult in the United States of
like younger people and stuff like that
who got so off on the idea of the
Haitian zombie thing and like taking the
zombie powder and coming back to life
that they were almost kind of like had
built a cult around this sort of
resurrection
you know reap of this constant rebirth
and stuff like that yeah so like I said
I've always been kind of more interested
in the old school type zombies so that's
why I wanted to do this the show about
this now most of you I would think if
you're into horror have probably seen
the movie the Serpent and the rainbow
and that came out in 88 I want to say
Bill Pullman was in it and it's kind of
like a polarizing movie like a lot of
years before that it might have been as
I was in high school I think when I saw
it yeah the book came out in 84 or 85 I
graduated in 87 so yeah it might have
been like think it was it might have
been like 82 like of you guys oh I've
got the Wikipedia page open right here
88 I was radiative a staple or so right
after I got out of high school yeah I
was still in high level then it was very
very loosely based on the book by Wade
Davis which was a nonfiction book huh
now Wade Davis is an anthropologist and
an ethno botanist meaning that he
studies how cultures and plants
Interactive's medicinally or as drugs or
whatever now the reason that he came to
write this book was because of a famous
case that occurred in well it actually
started in 1962 but they didn't find out
about it until 1980 in 1980 there was a
woman named Angelina Narcisse and she
was in her town in Haiti and she was in
the marketplace and she sees this man
walking toward her and he looks kind of
familiar and stuff like that and he says
I'm your brother clairvius and she says
clairvius narcisse died in 1962 yes you
know
yes and so she was kind of freaking out
about it but apparently he knew a bunch
of stuff about like his childhood like
he knew his childhood nickname that
nobody knew but them and he knew all
this other stuff so they eventually did
discover that this was indeed a man who
had supposedly died in 1962 what ended
up happening 1962 clairvius narcisse he
checked himself into the albert
schweitzer hospital there in haiti
because he was having a fever and body
aches and things like that so he checked
himself into the hospital there are
records of it so he checks in they give
him an examination and stuff like that
and he dies two doctors signed the death
certificate both of them had been
trained in America so it wasn't kind of
like yeah you know P I know people will
say it's like oh some you know a doctor
or whatever ya know these were both
American trained doctors and they both
declared him dead the day after that he
was buried now when they're talking to
clairvius now he says I was completely
lucid the whole time he's like I heard
them pronounce me dead I felt them pull
the sheet up over my face I felt them
put me in the ground and there was
nothing I could do about it he's like I
was paralyzed Wow
so he could still see everything he
could still hear everything man when I
was a kid I had these morbid fears of
being buried alive could you imagine
what that'd be like these variables it
is a very common fear and awe and
honestly I would wreck an tremendous
called buried alive and it's kind of a
history of people's fears about it and
like all the all that stuff they used to
build like all that [__] like where
they've had like bells and stuff comes
out of the air you can answer that you
could yell out there no they buried him
alive how did he didn't suffocate
because the day after he was buried the
book or the sorcerer he comes back and
digs the guy up but but there wasn't a
age where the air in the coffin was well
see I don't think they don't bury them
very deep it's not like here where they
buried them and there's like a layer of
cement or it's like I don't think they
bury them very deep in that and the
boxes are just kind of so there's a way
to get enough oxygen I would imagine you
better your what your metabolism is slow
down the point to where you don't you're
not freed maybe but usually people
suffer all kinds of brain damage
some of them do all right it you know it
does happen because of oxygen
deprivation Grune
but yes so he said that the next day a
guy came and dug him up and then he was
enslaved on a sugar plantation for two
years after which the bokor died and he
escaped now you might be asking well why
didn't he return to his family for 16
years
the reason according to him is that now
you might feel bad for clairvius
narcisse I mean this is a horrible
horrible thing to happen but evidently
he believed that it was his brother that
engineered him getting poisoned and
enslaved okay so he was waiting for his
brother to die all right before he came
back so it's not his brother put put the
sorcerer up to it yeah they don't know
like I don't know if there's any proof
of that exactly but that's what he
believed so so he said well I waited for
my brother to die before I came back to
contact the rest of my family because I
thought he was responsible for it all
right
I don't know what he was doing for those
ensuing 16 years he was just wandering
around so because I mean okay for a long
time there had been these kind of you
know all this folklore and urban legends
and stuff like that about zombies in
Haiti it's a very common urban legend
there but until clairvius narcisse came
along and they were actually able to
prove that yes this was the man that
died in 1962 and here he is alive again
it's the same dude you know people in
the United States started to get
interested in the case now one of the
people that got interested in the case
was a doctor named Nathan Kline and at
the time he had a graduate student named
Wade Davis who was studying anthropology
and ethnobotany
now Nathan Kline he was like okay now if
this zombie thing is real that it has to
be engendered through some kind of drug
right and it's like if we could figure
out what this compound is maybe we could
use it like as an anesthetic or
something like that we could use it for
medicinal purposes because they didn't
know what was in it mmm
zombie power yeah so they basically were
like what has to be something like that
so he sent Wade Davis down to Haiti to
study and try and figure out what this
rod now this was the early 80s so Wade
Davis went down there he was eventually
able to obtain eight different samples
from four different areas of this zombie
powder now none of them had the exact
same ingredient she's so good she
doesn't follow any recipe within jira
Pichet Aires asam people do but most of
them have real similar ingredients they
said almost seven out of eight of them
had dried pufferfish
yeah which of course contains
tetrodotoxin which is B causes paralysis
right they all contained ground human
bones usually when one preparation he
saw prepared he said that the guy
crushed a baby skull and put it in there
all right several of them also had the
stuff off like a marine toad right which
was some kind of some kind of weird
gross substance not poisonous exactly
but you know and most of them also had
either ground glass or some kind of like
irritating plant like itching pee or
something like that or why because this
is why most of them had ground glass or
or tarantula hairs or so exaggerated
Lissa's yeah because if they blew it on
you or got it on your skin it would make
you scratch right there by having open
wounds and it would get into your
bloodstream
so he brings these samples back and like
I said he saw he wrote the book de
serpent on the rainbow about his
experiences there he actually wrote
another book too in 1988 that was kind
of about the same thing but so he
brought it back they put the
preparations on some
shaved rats and things like that and it
caused the rats to go to get paralyzed
for a little while but then they woke up
and they were all right like they
recovered now what he didn't obtain a
sample of and I don't think anyone as
far as I know I don't think anyone has
obtained a sample but this is what they
feel like is probably happening now the
zombie powder is not used to keep the
people enslaved you know that's only
used for the death and resurrection
portion Lucas to keep the people
enslaved they think that there is
another compound they usually they take
sweet potatoes they make a paste out of
it and then they mix in datura which is
a plant which has atropine and
scopolamine in it not and if you yeah
and if you remember we did a show about
that about that what's it called the
devil juice or whatever it's like you
know it's like the Angels trumpets all
right called that kind of plant that has
the same kind of thing and that causes
you know amnesia pliability saying of
that nature and it's also thought that
you know the bokors that have these
zombies on their plantations working on
their plantations that they also feed
they they kind of feed them the datura
all the time which kind of makes them
lose their memory and lose their
identity and things like that but they
also feed them a diet with no salt in it
which makes them weak and kind of you
know not which is actually pretty clever
because that does happen if you don't
because you need salt you need a lot of
salt and you brought to maintain your
muscles and your brain function and
stuff like that so if they feed you a
low salt diet if yeah it weakens you and
makes you like less likely to run off
now the interesting thing too and I and
I think I'm not sure how widespread this
perception is I feel like people would
be like well isn't it kind of a lot of
trouble to make zombies just to like
work on your luggages you know but I
mean because especially because there's
a lot of unemployment in Haiti it's like
you know it should be easy to like find
oil to work on your sugar plantation
well it's because they don't make
zombies as slaves okay really not for
not from an economic standpoint
all right they make zombies because it's
a punishment I got so it's actually it's
kind of a way of keeping people in line
and keeping people like you know people
that break society's rules and stuff
like that they're seen as this is seen
as like the ultimate punishment right
because so so it's messing with you you
can hire a book or to go turn a guy's
turn a garden amento is not bigger
because you have to imagine I mean Haiti
which was occupied by the French the
French well you know they had slaves to
work on the sugar plantation when the
Haitian Revolution came in 1804 and the
French were driven out you know slavery
was abolished and things like that but
the memory of it was still very fresh
room after the Haitian Revolution they
had had beliefs and zombies before
because obviously the slaves had been
brought over from West Africa and they
had they had a similar type of belief
system there and they brought that with
them so they'd always had that and
legend about zombies but after the
Haitian Revolution the zombie sang kind
of exploded because the memory of
slavery was so still so fresh and they
thought well that would be the work that
would be worse than death mmm you know
being being dead and then coming back
going enslaved because they did believe
that the book [__] had the power to
bring the dead to bring the dead back to
life and enslave you and you would just
be at their beck and call forever yeah
so there's like a scary idea yeah so
that's why and I think that's why like a
lot of the book [__] got away because
most of the regular people didn't know
that they just engendered the through a
drug right magic yes they thought it was
magic because you know science is magic
really yeah as you guys just scientists
science is just magic that works yeah
pretty much yeah so that's kind of why
like I said that's why clairvius
narcisse
he think was zombified because
apparently according to some of his
family members he wasn't really the
nicest guy right yeah I guess he had
sort of burned a lot of bridges with his
family members he was he was supposed to
share part of his land with his brother
and his brother had a family to support
and evidently he
you wanted to keep all the land for
himself right and in Haiti I mean where
where agriculture is like a huge part of
their economy they take land rights
pretty serious yeah so his vengeance
yeah so the taxes family yes so the fact
that clairvius narcisse and like i said
he kind of seemed like a scumbag in
other ways like he went around knocking
up women and not supporting the children
and things like that
so he wasn't super well-liked so it kind
of came to pass that his brother got
pissed off at him hired a book or rug to
poison him and then bring him back from
the dead quote-unquote and that's how
that went actually tell you what let's
take a break right now and we'll just
cut throw a couple little short
commercials in there okay and then we'll
come back and talk a little bit more
about some zombies all right be back in
just a minute
[Music]
you
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour despair check out our
new list channel 13 o'clock in minutes
all the fun creepy topics of the main
podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
okay so is this zombie powder actually
work see that's there's kind of a lot of
controversy about this now you have to
think if the zombie phenomena is real if
people are actually getting buried and
being brought back and being enslaved
and like I said clairvius narcisse was
not the only person that has claim to
this all right
many many many other people in Haiti
have claimed that this has happened to
them his was just the most documented
case because they had records of his
deaths and they had all these you know
they had all these other things and he
knew a lot about his childhood and stuff
like that which a fakir wouldn't have
known but there are some Western people
that don't believe this
yeah well there was some controversy
arose because the samples that Wade
Davis brought back like I said they did
tests apparently they did test some of
them on rats and it did make the rats
you know go into paralysis and then they
came back and recovered and stuff like
that
however when other labs tried to test
the powder they said that most of them
had little to no trace of tetrodotoxin
in them now Wade Davis says well maybe
that might have been because one all the
preparations of the formula were
different because he got them from
different sorcerers and they all had
their own little recipes or whatever
he's like also the solution that you put
them in to test them might have
destroyed not to destroy it some of the
you know some of the drive maybe it's
got a real short half-life maybe where
it maybe gets a weak quickly yeah
something like that that's kind of what
he was arguing for since it couldn't
really be replicated you know as far as
I know that so some people thought that
maybe it was [__] that maybe every
single case of people coming back and
saying hey I got zombified was just you
know people's mistaken identity or you
know whatever but I don't know it does
seem like it's so widespread there and
it's so there are so many people
claiming that this happened to them and
they say the same things they say I
could hear and feel everything that was
going on when I got pronounced dead and
what I got buried and things like that
so it would seem that if those things
did happen the way they were
described it would have to be something
like that because the that drug from the
pufferfish it does have that effect all
right I mean like I said it's just like
the fugu fish in Japan that like you
know people people eat they have to
prepare it a certain way otherwise it
may if it makes you paralyze or they'll
kill you whoever some people skeptical
well they just hatin on it where they
just mean own it well I'm not really
sure it will science you know it's
Sciences you have to be skeptical
especially if it's something so
seemingly fantastic right as zombies but
like I said Wade Davis was not claiming
that the book [__] were bringing
people back from the dead just look like
it yeah he was just saying that I Oh
rabbit trick yeah that they were doing
like a faking deaths that weren't good
enough that to fool doctors and then
bringing the guy back and feeding them a
drug that made them pliant that's
basically what he was saying which is
not a crazy thing because there are
drugs that do that type of yet so the
thing is okay so later on Wade Davis
agreed to sell the book to Hollywood you
know he knew it was gonna be a horror
movie ok but you know he wasn't I just
ended up being serpent the rainbow yeah
well that was the name of the book okay
well the Satan actually I didn't like
the movie I didn't remember like I am
from what I remembered I thought I liked
to buy a pretty core I haven't seen it
for a long time Angemon career I liked
it at the time now I would like pretty
much the only they changed everyone's
named but the main character that was in
it was played by Bill Pullman he was an
anthropologist and ethnic biologist but
he wasn't named Wade Davis he was named
something else he was named Allen
something and he goes down to handy to
get the zombie powder and stuff like
that but I feel like I'm not really sure
I'm like I said I haven't seen in a
while I'm not really sure if the movie
posits that there really is like some
supernatural [__] going on or if or if
Bill Pullman character just is like
suffering under the effects of these
drugs yeah I couldn't tell because we're
in a movie he he gets drugged by like
the bokor and stuff and gets buried
alive and stuff like that there's that
very famous scene where he's like don't
bury me I'm not dead and stuff like that
now Wade Davis obviously did not try
society rather and so wisely and so that
part is not true and there was also a
bunch of stuff about I think like the
book or like was haunting his dreams and
like beheaded somebody not [__] like
that in in so in the sit on the silver
screen
zombies traditionally were kind of
portrayed like this up until George
Romero's up until George Romero yeah
really a fella goes to had one called
white zombie
yeah involved powders and yeah there
were like some short silent films that
were kind of about zombies I think the
first one was in 1919 so I know back
then I guess the rumors of zombie powder
had made it oh yeah thanks yeah okay
there wasn't proof yeah nobody proof
well yeah that's kind of how people got
interested at the time but there I think
there were some there was a US military
that were stationed in Haiti kind of in
the early 20th century and they knew
about it and they sent back well a lot
of their [__] was exaggerated like in
the early 20th century there was like a
really lot of kind of pulp novels that
were based off like all these scary you
know zombie witch doctors yeah they had
all these preparations and they could
they could hypnotize people to do their
bidding and all the other kind of stuff
so like I said it was exaggerated but
that's kind of that was where the
American perception came from okay
like I said 1919 I think was the first
short silent film that was based on that
type of thing white zombie with Bela
Lugosi was actually the first
full-length zombie movie the best thing
about white zombie is that Bela Lugosi's
character is named murder lissandra I'm
like that is awesome I wish that was my
[__] name but yeah so Bela Lugosi
plays basically a book or who kind of
uses his little magic powers or like
hypnotized there was another one called
I walked with a zombie that came out in
1943 I think and that was a
Jacques Tourneur and Val Lewton who also
made cat people which is a really hard I
also think it's weird that Night of the
Living Dead has become a definitive
zombie movie when that really wasn't
about zombies it wasn't it wasn't
originally intended to be about zombies
I went when I see Night of the Living
Dead it kinda
reminds me of last men on earth which is
more about vampires yeah that's what
kind of vampires right yeah yeah you had
last man on earth
that got spun into Omega man yeah which
got spun into I am Legend yeah which was
what the original book which original
call yeah good to know I can't remember
I don't like a zombie movie but it was
kind of about vampires went in and in
well in the Heston movie the vampires
were kind of spun into mutants yeah and
then we were watching that
that new series last night which kind of
reminded me of Van Helsing I'll decide
by serious if it's on Netflix well it's
kind of like kind of like last night on
earth through Mega Man it kind of is
yeah I didn't really realize it at the
time so it's very similar to Walking
Dead - because we round up like a few
survivors what's definitely there take
up they need you to Walking Dead so
that's what they did yes they just did
vampires and it's kind of like last
night on earth but it's not like this
it's not about one man it's about a
group yeah it's about a group so so in
that event is more like yeah and
actually I don't know if I'd recommend
it it's okay like we just kind of not
bad yeah we just kind of came across it
it's I liked the central conceit even
though I mean it posits that there have
always been these vampires but that they
were able to take over the earth because
there was like a huge it was like a huge
volcanic eruption or something like that
and so it made it made the skies go dark
so the vampires could come out in the
day they had net didn't have to like
creep around in the shadows and at night
all the time so it's kind of like kind
of similar to like 30 days of night
where the vampires go up to the Arctic
Circle where it's like dark for six
months and stuff like that which I
thought was a really good idea and then
there's kind of a whole thing about
aren't there like dumb ones and smart
ones because some can like talk they're
just like PDA that's like the Omega Man
and all of them are like feral out of
them all I'd take Omega Man I love that
movie
that was a good movie as good I honestly
I kind of I kind of liked the last man
on earth though the Vincent Price it was
good too but I think Omega Maggie I did
not like I did not like the Will Smith
one I imagine not at all
no terrible it seems to me and like I
said I haven't read the Richard Matheson
novel in a long time but I perceived
that the Vincent Price one was closest
to the book yeah
although it's hard to choose between
Omega Man and Night of the Living Dead
there's the animal or premise but very
different uh man I think I still take
Omega Man yeah yeah I think it would
Mathias and the cult living down here
ended like but I've had a lot this is
like like I said and this is why I kind
of ended up writing a story about it and
I don't know if writing the story really
kind of gave me any new insight into but
why why did that happen like why did the
zombie mythos that came from Haiti how
did that morph into what it is now like
not a living dead that broke the ground
with genre well yeah because if there
were rules and yeah somebody somewhere
along line called those zombies yeah
never mentioned didn't either and no he
doesn't mention that never mention and
they only really briefly mentioned how
it happened it was the radiate space
radiations we should drop them back well
they don't they never say it they never
definitively say they say does this
space yeah they're like that I could be
it maybe yeah yeah which you know I
don't know I guess that's a good fit but
it just seems weird that it's become so
now as the Night of the Living Dead
series unfolded became day to dead and
all the dead
I don't remember if they ended up
calling them zombies in any of those did
they that's in this is another weird
thing and the Walking Dead is like the
worst culprit for this it seems like I
mean I haven't seen every zombie movie
or zombie show ever yeah you know ever
made but they they don't call them
zombies even though in real life that's
immediately what you would call them
odds are the only thing that don't exist
in the in the dammit in the Nazi very
weird to me that word doesn't seem to
exist yeah that's very weird to me
because it in a way it kind of chips
away as a realism because you know that
if something like that happened in real
life
everyone everybody would call them that
into in fact [__] some of the you know
quote-unquote zombie movies they've made
lately like well not lately but in the
past twenty years or so you know like
twenty eight days later those got called
zombies even though technically they're
not zombies because they're not dead
people okay
they're just infected people right so if
you had called them infected people and
not zombies and fine but walking dead
that was one of the things that always
kind of weirded me out of it still think
about what kind of walkers or what are
what lighters fighters that is it who
the [__] would call them that nobody
everybody would call them that everybody
on earth would call them zombies did you
call them the dead dog yeah which you
know that's fine that's you would call
them that but biters yeah who would call
them that nobody nobody and that it
takes it out like I said I love the
walking dead but that takes me right out
of the story that's really thought what
would happen that's not what would
happen and I feel like a lot of zombie
movies have that whereas it's like they
won't call them that for some reason
well that was one thing that I kind of
liked about that van Helsing show we
were watching last night they
immediately did come out and say well it
sounds dumb but they're vampires
vampires right because they are vampires
right they're dead people they came back
and they drink the blood of vampires now
the price and that Vincent Price movie
last night on earth
a vampire was kind of like a zombie yeah
well all is different you have to think
that I mean the two mythological
creatures are very similar
well the way a lot of some of the
zombies were described is basically a
zombie as you need me a lot of times the
way of vampires described is a zombie
basically and it comes up out of the
grave it's nasty yeah on all over it and
maybe that's kind of where the switch
happened between the hey schism because
maybe it kind of got intermingled with
the vampire thing because initially
vampires were kind of gross yeah I mean
favor
they were alike goals also yeah I think
in in the Romero night a Living Dead
the ghouls actually were conceived in
this primitive vampires yeah that's what
it well even now I like I haven't had
bread Fetty of Anne Rice's stuff in a
long time but didn't she have she
mentioned some kind of feral yeah Myers
dude that was all you know look at daddy
and rich and everything in the book
vampire lestat in the story of Lestat
Genesis when Lestat was with a newly
made vampire out in Europe he tells the
story where he finds a walking corpse
and destroys it if it was a mindless
walking course yeah
now you're led to believe that it was a
vampire it was about it was very
primitive and honestly a lot of the
folklore about vampires that comes from
like Eastern Europe and stuff like that
they weren't portrayed as like really
suave no Intel or even particularly
intelligent maybe cunning but they were
thought they were almost kind of
portrayed as their animalistic
animalistic and in the original stories
they actually only went after their own
family members I don't think they just
went after everybody I think that if I'm
remembering it correctly I think like
the Eastern European legends that's why
you had to like put a stake through the
heart stuff like that because they come
back to their family home and try to eat
everybody in there not so much just
random people I mean even in Bram
Stoker's original Dracula
you know Dracula was not they look like
Bela Lugosi he looked like not Ferrante
right he looks like a rat what I know
that like he was kind of yucky and gross
yeah so maybe that's what it is maybe
there's just some kind of
cross-pollination between the zombie
thing and the whole family because it's
they're both like keeps coming back from
the dead and feasting on the living
whether drinking their blood or is you
know they're all vampires dogs are all
vampires uh yeah I guess Jen also stated
to meet the mutants from from Omega man
we're also vampires it's just a
different way I always kind of perceived
them as they were they were albinos
psychopathic albinos that couldn't stand
the light now they didn't drink blood
true and and they don't think they
didn't die hey we're here where they
have Mortal know what I'm in as they
never died and were reborn
oh right understand they're a normal
person then all of a sudden they became
their eyes would go white and then they
were Psychopaths they'd attack you if
you yeah if you weren't one of them so
yeah okay so yeah I think I went that
way they were more like they were reborn
of something else but they never really
died in kind of a crusade no right okay
so in that way kind of like gosh we're
getting adult baby I love this oh I
didn't like semantic discussions about
what the zombie was
yeah yeah well you know that's kind of
like I'm still gonna say my favorite one
is Omega man there's something about the
Hat the Hat the heft is almost like the
Shaq hasn't called a Qi you know it's
crop top yeah yeah nothing like seeing a
Heston ride around and riding around in
an abandoned LA on a four in a Ford
Mustang convertible with a Smith &
Wesson submachine gun yeah yeah Wesson
did make a submachine MK 760 he knows
all about that's pretty cool that's
pretty [__] I want to get movie again
now yeah we should probably watch that
again we watched last man on earth dish
a couple weeks here but uh yeah I was
kind of like them she got a left
enterprise man he's up yeah I mean
something else I find interesting too is
that I think particularly in the United
States we kind of have a perception of
Voodoo the religion being bad or evil
like look at all the horror movies that
were made about like the believers and
like I said servant of the rainbow and
stuff like that whereas kind of like the
entire religion is just broken down -
they make knowledge that they take
people's souls and [__] like that
because United States is a heavy
Protestant influence if it's not
Protestantism it's from it from the
devil in Baden Buddha basically you
could is basically Catholic well yeah I
mean basically I was like I said it's
West African you know sort of it's a
rebooted consult yeah animist religions
mixed women when the slaves are brought
to Haiti and we're forced to convert to
Christianity you know they kind of
intermingled what's that syncretism
right they call that they were they kind
of intermingled the two things yeah you
know that became Santeria it became
Macumba became voodoo with you know yeah
because the whole interpretations yeah I
mean the whole you know bullying it's a
bleeding st. yeah well yeah that's the
same thing the whole belief system of
Voodoo is simply that they do have you
know a main overarching God figure to
Sandy but the overarching God figure
does not I mean you can't talk to him
directly no but you got Jesus in there
know you've got married y'all all these
little Padres and say and then
goes down a little demon type and in
nature spirits and well yeah then you
have the lower which are like spirits
and you can ask them for stuff and all
of the low I have
Catholic saint equivalents yeah so like
you can ask them for specific things so
when they have the rituals like to ask a
particular logo for something like each
particular Lowa has their little
specialty and they have their little
color that's associated with them and
their foods that's associated with them
so you just have your ritual you wear
the color scarf of the lower that you
want to talk to you know you give them
cigarettes or whatever particular food
is their thing and ask them for whatever
so like I said it's no it's not a lot
different than Catholicism really you're
you're essentially just talking to what
is the middleman it's an integral part
of it in Central and South America
there's no difference between
Catholicism and macumba macumba couldn't
exist without Catholicism it's it's just
a continuation yeah that's okay okay
here's here's a good example
it's the expanded universe yes I get but
yeah expand universe you have you know
Star Trek and then the expanded unit and
Star Wars and then the expanded universe
you have Catholicism and then the
expanded universe they have to work they
work together yeah they're part of the
same thing and like I said it's just
more of a focus and expanded version of
course it's fanfic yes fanfiction all
right it's folk made yeah that's what
and like I said I always found it a lot
more I mean Catholicism you know I'm an
atheist so I don't really I don't really
think any of this shit's real or
anything like that but I always thought
I mean Catholicism is beautiful all this
all the Saints and all that stuff Adria
yeah it's very stylish stuff and all the
candles and everything love it but you
know so I come to golf to you know I
know that kinda [__] but there's always
something I always kind of liked about
the the more voodoo seemed
interpretation of that where it's a like
you said it's like a folk interpretation
yeah of Catholicism where it's like all
mixed together and I always really liked
that it's that I never really perceived
it as negative even though a lot of
people seem to but you like I said you
got to think that zombie thing that's
like a teeny little part of and like I
said that's
that's just punishing people yeah well
you know it's not like a large part of
their police's that could also be seen
as bringing justice doesn't necessarily
it I think they're like somebody does
something assholey they're like want to
turn your ass into a zombie but see how
you like that you know I mean that's all
that's all it is it's sanctions yeah and
like I said it's not really a huge part
of their religion you know per se it's
just kind of like a little thing that
sometimes they do when they're mad at
you a lot of that stuff that it just
involves a an expanded universe priest
okay he's not really from the Catholic
Church but he's working kind of like
obliquely he recognizes the power of the
Catholic Church but when poor people
need something done and maybe they don't
want to go to the to the big church they
want to go to their little fault Church
yeah and have him do some stuff to help
them and this is all I'm saying
it may really did well and they don't
have any they don't have any conflict
about that no ma'am it's all the same
Anna puts on good show you know I've
seen em in Brazil yeah kind of bleh
shows Macumba which is kind of blade
same thing yeah similar and there's
going to be chicken sacrifices but a lot
of that has to do with the priests going
to eat that chicken yeah parts of it
yeah that's for parties payment you know
he's not going to it in front everybody
else but you know because I'm I look
given some packs of cigarettes to the
spirits now they do actually sacrifice
that stuff you'll find bowls you know
like a flat bowl on the sidewalk with a
pack of cigarettes in it and part of a
chicken wing with feathers on it and
maybe some cards at a candle and it'll
stay there you know in a poor country
it'll just stay there nobody will tell
no one's gonna take that that's Jude
that's not for you no that's for the
spirit you can really start early have
been do me a big trouble if you said
that I never really thought it was a big
deal because I was growing up and you
know as a teenager in the country that
where that was just normal behavior and
really I I really didn't see the
difference between that and Catholicism
there isn't it for the same there isn't
a difference well like I said look at
look at Catholics fellow the cabin
church would not say that that Boulevard
they wouldn't but you know like I did it
the same like I said you know you know a
Star Wars purist is not going to accept
to expand you
[Laughter]
and you know yeah it's the same [__]
though well yeah that's what I never
really saw that much of a difference
because like I said Catholics they do
the same thing they're making a void by
burning candles and incense as if you're
making an offering you're asking yeah
for something in particular
right to a particular st. hey you know
it's prayer and yeah yeah it's the same
you're just in treating series it's not
weird yeah in that sense it's just
there's no difference I don't think now
the Mexicans are doing it you know it's
not centrum work a here no yeah drug
dealers you don't mean was there they're
giving offerings to basically sound like
a demonic force so they don't get caught
they don't get caught you know I'm just
well yeah that's what anything and I
feel like probably and I don't know if
this is true maybe somebody can point me
to a study that shows that it's true but
I feel like people that are involved in
criminal activity are probably more
superstitious than most oh yeah because
they have shown that superstition really
kind of ramps up the more insecure your
livelihood is the more you know what I
mean the more unsure you are you know oh
I'm going to get caught or oh my crops
are going to fail or something like that
and criminal intellect is kind of graded
on a curve you know I mean they're
criminals are get their Dom yeah yeah I
mean it was kind of the Dumber you are
the more you're gonna believe in crazy
[__] yes that's that's four that's
pretty sure I'm gonna go out and do
something is really high risk I could
probably get killed so I need to believe
in this imaginary thing that will help
me yeah give it help me get away with
well like I said the more they have
shown that there are more superstitious
beliefs in professions where there's a
lot of uncertainty like phishing or
things like that like you know people
that go on they don't know how their
livelihoods going to go that to enter
that year yeah that kind of social
gamblers yeah so it's an attempt to gain
some control over your situation when
you don't really have any itches right
makes you feel better and but in a
self-fulfilling prophecy sometimes it
does make you do better because it makes
you more confident yeah so you know it
works and I'm getting a little bit
off-topic well that's okay well actually
we're almost at the end of the show so
let's do let's close out a little bit by
we got we got
topics coming up yeah that's what I was
going to say because this is we wanted
to do this because we've had like a
really really lot of Awesome topic or
West lately yes so much on them yeah and
we wanted to like let you guys know like
when when stuff was coming up so you
wouldn't think we'd like forgotten about
everybody so the topics we have coming
up in this order we're doing EVPs that
Mario bocce that radio that and EVPs in
general so that's going to be a next one
we're doing one on Elizabeth báthory
after that yeah we're doing a revisit of
summer wind I think it's right we have a
get on as a guest the guy who owns
what's left the summer went yeah or you
know yeah just how own the blueprints to
it yeah yeah he's got the blueprints yet
and he owns a property I think to them
yeah a lot half-ass really I would guess
but but yeah he wanted to come on the
show and kind of talk about our lands
and the housing and everything like that
so we're doing a revisit on that we're
doing somebody mentioned Bill Cooper and
some of like zoom Jays predictions so we
were going to do a show about doomsday
predictions a general probably put
Miller rights in there too
yeah that's just that kind of stuff we
wanted to do a show about that somebody
wanted to do a show about Anton LaVey
yeah we'll do the whole Satanists job
we'll do one of those we're going to do
a spontaneous combustion show okay we're
going to do a Norse mythology show oh
that would be good
somebody asked for the wine bill chicken
coop murders like a true crime never
heard of them
yeah I hadn't either so I'm gonna have
to like research that we're gonna do a
show about that we're going to do a
horrors of Mount Everest okay yeah so we
got a require go ahead upon a month yeah
we got a request to do weird genetic
mutation okay which we can do that now a
friend of mine wanted me to do like we
did we talked a little bit about goat
men on our cryptid show okay and she was
telling me that she's like there are
tons of different legends about
different kinds of goat men and stuff
like that she's like I love it if you
just do a whole show about different
goat meadows that's if we might do a
show about that day okay
and we're going to do one on like
ancient Egypt and like myths about
ancient Egypt and stuff because it's
similar to the bio one but we'll do Andy
and we'll Prague into a Halloween
special yeah we haven't decided what
we're going to do for Halloween yet but
we want to do something kind of cool
like a Halloween special kiss
Halloween's my very
your holiday I guess that's okay if you
enjoyed the show please support the show
on patreon
yes it's patreon Comcast I'll put a link
in the description we're creeping up I
think we're almost at what $40 yeah
something like done okay well 45 45 some
like yeah I think we are shooting for
2500 but uh one laughing million dollar
I have that I'd be happy well yeah that
would be awesome
oh yeah so please support the show on
patreon we also still have shirts
available that does as well dot-com
flesh 13 o'clock yeah we're gonna start
running shirt commercials because these
shirts are awesome you guys got to see
them
I know I'm still going to make more I
know I say that every time but I'll take
away silver for the shirt commercials
and you'll do it all with hundreds all
with your announcer away yeah do my
announcements and the new shirt from 13
o'clock Chris well predict yes pretty
good shirt would be worn and like I said
if you um want to listen to the audio
podcast like I said it's been moved I'll
put a link to the iTunes in the
description and a link to the blog and
everything like that and I think that'll
do it for episode 51 about voodoo and
zombies and all okay it's okay subject
not my favorite subject is okay well you
had a good time thanks thanks for your
vote of confidence
- hello helpful he is so helpful you see
what afternoon alright see you guys next
Tuesday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
now powers
[Music]
ah
yeah
a Casillas not
Shanta my girl
you
[Music]